Speaker 1: I continue to, in bewildered fashion,
wait for someone who is running against Donald
Trump in the 2024 nomination, or might soon
be running against Trump to levy some kind
of criticism of Donald Trump. Some kind of policy
critique, draw some distinction between what they
would do and what Donald Trump would do. We have
a couple of examples here. And the one that is
getting weirder and weirder by the day is former
South Carolina governor and former ambassador to
the United Nations under Donald Trump, Nikki
Haley. Nikki Haley has announced that she is
running against Trump. Right. Okay, good. So,
like, what would you do differently? Well,
nothing. But I'm younger and I'm a woman and
I'm a minority. Identity politics has been Nikki
Haley's approach so far. It is now been weeks. And
Nikki Haley went on Fox News and she was asked,
Are you going to draw any distinction with
Donald Trump? And her latest thing is, well,
let's see if he criticizes me first.
Speaker 2: You're not going to kick
sideways. But we've seen Donald Trump on the
debate stage, and I guarantee you he will kick
sideways and he will come after you. Yeah. So
and you're going to have to kick back when I'm
kicked. I kick back. And what will your argument
against him be? Well, let's wait and see if he's
got a criticism first. He hasn't done anything.
He hasn't said anything. So I know everybody.
Speaker 1: Wants that's very much untrue.
Speaker 2: Talk about Trump. But Martha truly
and we had a couple of thousand people in South
Carolina. We had packed rooms in New Hampshire.
Not one person asked me about Donald Trump,
not one. And now we're in Iowa. People really
want to talk about the issues. And I think
that's a lot of it. They're done with the
status quo. They're done with talking about all
the old school things. They want to talk about
how we're going to go forward. And I think what
we need to make sure we tell American families
is we're going to stop this socialism creep,
that we're saying we're going to stop this.
Speaker 1: Any criticisms
of Trump socialism as bad.
Speaker 2: Statism that's happened around our
country? We're going to make people stand for
America again and be proud of America.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So remember, she says as
soon as Trump criticizes me, I will criticize him.
Trump brutally criticized her last week. Remember,
he said she was such a terrible governor that he
made her ambassador as a favor to the people of
South Carolina to get her out of the state. He
posted, quote, on truth True Social Trump posted
last week the greatest thing Nikki Haley did for
our country in the great state of South Carolina
was accepting the position of U.N. ambassador so
that the incredible then Lieutenant Governor Henry
McMaster, could be governor of South Carolina,
where he has done an absolutely fantastic job.
That was a big reason why I appointed Nikki to
the position. It was a favor to the people I
love in South Carolina. She's basically saying I
have criticisms of Trump, but I'm going to wait
till he criticizes me. Hard to find a more serious
criticism than that. And then in addition to this,
Trump just a few days ago saying there are
people out there with no polling support,
basically auditioning for vice president.
When Trump said the following, nobody else
was running. It was only Nikki Haley that this
could be applied to. A lot of people are right
now auditioning. You know that a lot of.
Speaker 3: People a lot of people that
are running it 1%, 2%.
Speaker 1: 3%, no percent.
We have a couple that are joining there at no
percent. I say I wonder what they're doing. I
think they're auctioning right now. So they're
auditioning right now for vice president. In a
sense, they are kind of auctioning themselves
off Trump's Freudian slip there, that Trump
slip. There may be more Freudian than we might
think, but this was something we suggested. I
kind of agree with Trump. I do think there
is an element of let me run to get attention,
but not criticize Trump, draw no distinctions
whatsoever from Trump on policy and see if maybe
that can get me the vice president ship. So that's
Nikki Haley still unwilling or unable or whatever
to draw any distinctions other than identity
distinctions between her and the guy she is
running against. Let's next talk about another
guy who might be entering the race, Tim Scott.